Did you ever do that in studio?
I feel like our thing
cause you do sex and candy.
No,
no,
no.
I know I did.
Do you want that?
You want to know,
okay,
this is my version of
the songs by the way,
when I covered so many songs I just,
I just Kinda do what I think it is.
That song was a song that I liked
the first few times and it came out.
I thought it was interesting because
I'd never heard a song like that and um,
I kind of grew up.
But you,
your version of it,
it's very different.
It's a little bit faster I think.
Well it's cooler.
It's a good song,
man.
I,
that's a very good song.
I liked it a lot is when I
often like warm myself up with.
So yeah.
But again,
this is my version and you know,
if I butcher it up,
y'all just going to have
to dig it like that.
You know what I mean?
Hang now downtown Bam,
Su,
Su
Cherry Pan
flag six.
Can they,
who was that lounge and Matt G at CASS?
Do you need a steals?
The show.
The show is a tree
downtown
platform.
Double Swede
Pack.
A disco
last no six.
Who's that?
Who's that cast
TV upstairs.
Last name six.
Can they
BU's that lounge
chair who's at cast?
Leo Stills in that direction.
My spin match.
I could understand the words in that.
Like there's,
there's a bunch of the words in that
other one where I don't know what the fuck
who was saying devious
stairs in my direction now.
I know.
I thought it was like beefeater
stairs and my direction somewhere.
I know I threw a really
bad cold somewhere.
Please.
It was beautiful.
Kept it moving so hopefully it did work.
I love the slang that I smell.
They're real slow and they do it too.
Like
you know,
it's real.
I think the guy who was singing that song,
the original dude,
it's a great version,
but it's the version of
a is trying to get laid.
He's like,
he's trying to be sexy.
It's being a little sexy.
He's working on it.
I fuck.
You'll still get laid
and it is a sexy song.
It is very sexy
fucking sexy song.
If you imagine what Saks and
candy would actually smell like,
though,
that'd be a fucking weird gummy
bears and yeast infections.
I was thinking snickers bars and bleach
rats.
They
snatched.